dangerous wildfires are spreading across
the western part of the country hot
temperatures and drybrush are fueling
the flames at least four new fires were
reported in Southern California
yesterday another wildfire grew to more
than 1,600 acres in northern Montana
Jamie yuccas shows us how conditions are
expected to get even worse as the week
goes on two and a half acres so far no
rest late into the night Tuesday for
Southern California firefighters this
fire is burning uphill and it is burning
in some pretty thick brush a water
dropping helicopter worked into the
early morning hours to try to contain
the fire which continued to burn about
20 miles east of Los Angeles it came
after a day of fighting fast-moving
wildfires across the Southland a
wildfire in a farming community about 40
miles east of LA quickly grew to 40
acres Tuesday burning at least one
structure people in the area had little
warning it went up fast those living
here work quickly to move their animals
and livestock out of harm's way
about 10 miles to the south another
wildfire is burning this fire quickly
erupted to almost 400 acres no
structures were threatened it's not
expected to be contained until sometime
later today ventura county fire that has
their hands full with this and this
brush fire west of los angeles snarled
holiday traffic after coming dangerously
close to the busy 101 freeway really
frightening here for suppo turists
officials say the fire burned 50 acres
the hot dry conditions are expected to
continue this week with temperatures
reaching the 90 degree mark for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles